you do good you're rewarded you get
better prices you get better treatment
you do bad you're canceled that's it
period And so you get your performance
built in because everything you do has
immediate consequence on your life
General Spaulding welcome to the show
thank you it's great to be here what do
you know about what's happening inside
of Shanghai right now
well I mean I think I'm as informed as
everybody else is which is I'm looking
at all the Twitter videos and uh and all
the Articles so
um you know the specifics it sounds like
you know it's fairly similar to the
Wuhan lockdown where they were keeping
people
um you know in their uh in their in
their Apartments I think the thing
that's um that they've moved on to is if
you're quarantined like they just take
your pet right away and and you know
there's no like I I think they've gotten
more efficient at defining how they
Implement a lockdown
and you know a lot of these decisions
that were probably painful in the very
beginning like in Wuhan like what do we
do with about these pets they've made
the decision this is what we're going to
do and
um you know it's it's basically they've
got a checklist now and one of the
things that you've you've um find out
about living in China is there's
checklists for everything right and you
you go through the checklist and you
make sure that you hitting all the
things and and the checklist now is you
know pretty pretty involved so I think
they've perfected what they think a
lockdown should be and that's what
you're seeing in in Shanghai yeah I've
seen videos of bags of cats alive in the
streets I've seen videos of dogs
seemingly being sort of killed slash
immobilized slash disposed of which is
I think those cats are going to be
disposed of I think that's you know they
are alive but I think they're they're
going to be disposed of is is that my
the impression that I've gotten from
everything that I've seen what do you
think is the reason for doing that are
they worried that they're a vector of
transmission are they worried that if
you have a pet you're more likely to go
outside and break quarantine
I I would I would imagine that is
they're a vector because I mean pets can
get coronavirus so I would imagine they
believe it's a vector of transmission
you know if they're going to quarantine
the people they're going to quarantine
the pets
um they don't really
you know they they can't really kill the
people although you know
uh when you look at the wiggers or or
the falun gong you know they're not they
don't really have a lot of problem with
those types of things but they're you
know at least at this point it's just
the animals that they're after
I saw a tweet that said 25 million
people in lockdown in Shanghai policed
by drones that have facial recognition
and give orders people who go out on
their balconies without masks are fine
directly from their cbdc accounts
yeah I mean it's awesome isn't it I mean
think about it the what you know the
technology that we created in Silicon
Valley and you basically
you know what the Chinese have done is
they've taken a systems engineering
approach to uh Society right so they
wanna they wanna basically automate how
Society performs and you know if you
think of it from a manufacturing
perspective for example you know we we
um talk about Six Sigma and the idea is
that you eliminate all
um you know anomalies and you make sure
that your you know whatever errors that
are causing systemic anomalies you get
rid of them and so in a sense they've
taken those principles of manufacturing
and using the tools of Silicon Valley
which are really this ability to harvest
data and mine it and then and then use
it to to
um basically cancel those that are
outside that are anomalies they have
taken systems engineering in this I.T
system that we built in the west and
combined it to create a way to automate
their society and and it's performance
base you do good you're rewarded you get
you know better prices you get better
treatment you do bad you're you're
canceled that's it period And so you get
your performance built in because
everything you do has immediate
consequence on your life just like you
said with the drones like somebody's
going to come there and they're going to
charge your account if you mess up now
you know that's something that's never
existed it's it's essentially like the
concept of the panopticon which is a
prison that was designed so that at any
point a prisoner would think somebody is
watching them and so what they what you
find with these kind of situations when
you're always being watched is that
people modify their behavior to ensure
that you know they're not going to be
punished and and so what they're trying
to get is this digital panopticon where
you're always being watched you know
what the rules are you know if you break
the rule you're going to be punished and
so you get the behaviors and that's
really what they're trying to get I want
these behaviors I don't want those
behaviors and I'm going to design a
system that that automatically limits
those behaviors yeah well I mean with
the panopticon it's kind of like a a
wheel and spoke design right so in the
middle of it you have potentially one
God sat on the swiveli chair and going
out away from him all the way around in
360 degrees or all of the different
cells the difference here is that it's
not because of how scalable technology
is you don't just need to have one guard
that might be looking you could scale
technology to the point where you are
always being watched all the time right
they're actually because AI can do it
right precise you don't need and the AI
never takes a you know you know a p
break and never you know maybe yeah ai's
like running man it's running in real
time and so uh I mean when you think
about it from you know logically if you
were going to take an engineer
an engineer's approach to
um political science it's the perfect
way that an engineer would design a
system because
everybody you know and there's so many
of these dystopian movies that take this
approach where you basically just
engineer Society so that everybody does
what they're supposed to
I mean it's it's terrifying but it is
strange uh the
lack of limits that a bureaucratic
dictatorial regime uh opens up in
technology that there are certain areas
of Technology how they can be
implemented how they can be integrated
with other uh elements of society uh
that when you don't have a democracy and
you have fewer human rights there's a
whole new world of uh technocratic
overreach that can be can be garnered
right well and and the other thing um is
that you know and and what this has
traditionally been what China has
benefited from its connection to the
west and that is anomalies aren't always
bad like you have people that commit
crimes but other anomalies are you
invent stuff you're Innovative you
create new things that have never
existed before you know people go to the
Moon you know you create an iPhone these
are also anomalies uh just like doing
bad things or anomalies so the problem
is when you start to create this system
systematic approach to
um you know Society
you're you're getting rid of all
anomalies you're not just getting rid of
the bad ones you're also getting rid of
a lot of the good ones too and the way
and the reason China's been able to get
away with this is because they could
just go to the West who has the good and
the bad and take the good leave the bad
and and you know what what you see
happening as a as a consequence of
coronavirus where a lot of the policies
that you're seeing in Shanghai were
implemented also in the west you know
countries in the west that are
democracies we're basically taking the
same policies
that China was in terms of lockdowns in
in all of these other restrictions and
so what happens is over time and and
this so China seeks to be the dominant
system in the world and then have all
systems look like it which is kind of
the same thing that the US and the UK
decided to do after the end of World War
II we think all societies should be
democracies because not only um we think
that's the right way to go it also
protects you know our vision of the
system and that our democracy isn't
coming under threat or pressure from
those uh Nations that think differently
well the China thinks the same way and
so what it's been able to do in the two
years of the coronavirus is really
slowly begin to move democracies into
its form of thinking about the
relationship between the state and the
individual you know the state has power
over the individual and therefore the
individual should do whatever the state
says without question this has been How
the West has basically adapted the
Chrono of ours and with things like
contact tracing in the west you're
beginning to see the technology be
brought in to enable That vaccine
um you know passports digital vaccine
backboards passports is another thing so
I mean you're seeing the homogenization
of the international order
in a way that's completely opposite of
how it was envisioned after the end of
World War II between the US and UK
what's happening with famine I've been
seeing tweets and news stories and stuff
about famine in Shanghai is that true
got any idea well I don't know if
there's famine uh so much as at least
yet so much as if you're locked up and
you can't get the food
you're gonna be you're going to be
hungry I mean I I lived in uh Minot you
know flying B-52s and we had a snowstorm
one time and I was in my house for a
week you know finally I had to break out
and go get milk and some other things I
mean I think that's what they're running
into is you know you after you're in
there's only so much stuff that you're
prepared to do in quarantine and then if
you can't leave to go get food that's a
problem but surely the Chinese
government must know that this is going
to happen right you lock people down you
don't allow them to leave to go and get
food there are certain things that you
need to do and I guess maybe as well
this is one of the reasons that perhaps
the killing of pets I'm pretty sure that
yeah Vector of transmission will be one
of them but just if you have a pet
you've got to go outside to go to the
bathroom yeah good point so have a walk
so I just think there's more and more
situations there have you got any idea
about why it is that there's some videos
floating around of the Chinese
government or the enforcement agency
breaking into people's apartments and
tasing them and taking them to sort of
covid ice isolation facilities I've seen
some awful videos and you never know on
the internet right you see a video and
you go this could be from
2009 during the whatever whatever crisis
yeah um but these videos that look like
kind of individual porta-potties and
everybody's got their heads stuck out
yeah
um I I don't know what that is but
there's definitely videos floating
around of the Chinese government
breaking into people's apartments and
and sort of tasing them and taking them
away do you have any idea what's
happening there
well um I think it's I think it's all
related to hey you may have had a
positive test and now you're going to go
spend time in the Pokey
um I it doesn't surprise me for Shanghai
what surprises me is you see the same
thing in Australia they got the same
basically
camps where they send people to like I
can see it in China I can see it in
Shanghai it makes sense to me but when I
see it happening in a in a country
that's supposed to have you know
something related to the Bill of Rights
and and and you know the rule of law and
you're saying hey this is what they're
instituting that's what really bothers
me because Shanghai I totally expect
this kind of behavior I remember I
remember you know the just a concern for
the well-being of people is different
there you know I've seen people in the
most horrid situations in China I
remember one time one of my neighbors
was moving and the moving truck shows up
with the crates and there's no people
like where are all the people and they
take the lid off the one of the crates
and all the people come out of the crate
they they were basically sealed up in
the crate and that's how they had
transmitted them or transported them to
the work site so when you think about
hey you concern for the well-being of
people that's not what you get in in
China you know it's just not the system
so I'm not surprised to see it
um it is it is their system
um and what I'm surprised is that it's
been able to be replicated in the west
does it
put into slightly harsher contrast
accusations of
fascists totalitarian regime overreach
and slavery and Monday racism and stuff
like that when we do have kind of this
very I mean look at India which has an
explicit caste system right which is
still unbelievably terrifying I've only
just started learning about this
um and then you have China where I mean
the detention camps actually look like
they're getting worse not better now and
it just seems to be this sort of
blinkers on view I noticed that the
current
um Hollywood push especially from Disney
uh but the whole Hollywood push around
the don't say gay bill from Florida
didn't seem to extend to the most recent
Harry Potter film which got released in
China and had the only six seconds of
LGBT content in there which suggested
that Dumbledore had previously been in a
relationship with this other guy uh They
removed that especially for the Chinese
Edition so you do have what seems like
like double standards either willful
willful ignorance uh and or outright
double standards coming from the West
when they're looking at their own world
versus just complete uh disregard for
what's happening over in China
well I mean if you think about it
um and you and you look at kind of in
particular not just the end of World War
II the Cold War but after the end of the
Cold War and say the 30 years after the
end of the Cold War
um and you look at you know whose
prerogatives you know Nations around the
world
um
listened to it was America right they
were listening to I mean America was um
the most powerful had the most powerful
economy the most productive economy and
um and that economic heft and the
willingness to use that economic half to
build up other countries like the
Marshall Plan or uh rebuilding Japan or
Korea after all these countries after
World War II
and then you realize that over the
course of those 30 years that power that
economic productivity the supply chain
of the world if you will has shifted
from America to China now has allowed
China to take the mantle of America and
so this idea that you know it's
um
and when I lived in Shanghai from 2002
to 2004 you know all of my neighbors
were building you know factories in the
Shanghai special economic zone and big
companies big U.S corporations
and what those business Executives would
tell me is like we're going to change
China to be more like America you know
the more that we're integrated
economically with this Society the more
China is going to change to be more
liberal they're going to be you know the
beginning except our principles and
values and of course the Chinese
Communist Party determined after
Tiananmen Square that that was
absolutely not going to happen and so
while it was a little bit hubris on our
part what's actually happened is the
reverse has happened is that now rather
than U.S corporations spreading the
values of Liberty democracy rule of law
free trade it's that U.S corporations
are now responding to the to where the
the economic power lies in the world and
they're spreading the same authoritarian
or totalitarian principles that China
wants to espouse so it should not be
surprising that we're seeing this shift
in our corporate sector in our financial
sector away from hey we're going to
promote the the the principles of
America to we're going to promote the
principles of the Chinese Communist
party because that's where our bread is
buttered so there's there's a there's a
strong tie between hey you're
economically powerful to hey you get to
you get to draft The Narrative that's
what the Chinese figured out like the
the Soviets were like Hey we're gonna
we're gonna go out you with weapons the
Chinese are we're going to go out with
you with money and economics and finance
and we're going to use that and not just
you know our the power of our
productivity and product productive
economy but we're going to invest in the
emerging market economies to the extent
that they look towards us not the US
right so it's no longer going to be the
US dictating how what are the principles
and rules of the international order
it's China and so that's what we're
seeing play out you know on a on a daily
basis what I would agree with is yes in
terms of the power economically that
China has and also supply chain too so
whether that be Downstream or stream
from whatever we need what I don't think
they've managed to do just yet is take
on the mantle culturally that America
had right that sort of cultural leader
people following that way the American
dream I'm not seeing yet people in the
west look to the culture of China
outside of the corporate world and say
oh I want a Chinese fashion and Chinese
I mean like K-pop is the closest thing
that I've seen to that even Japan I was
thinking about this either I'm aware
that this is not just one like
homogeneous Zone over there but just
generally I've seen Eastern cultural
influence seem to wane a little bit
anime uh the sort of the the push that
we had maybe about sort of 10 to 15
years ago with stuff like Pokemon
um I don't know that's been an
interesting thing for me to observe that
being said
in developing nations you know Belton
roads
um initiative stuff
I don't know whether that's the same
case I don't know whether there's some
countries in Africa that have received
tons and tons of money from China and
not only look to them as saviors and uh
collaborators financially but then also
perhaps might be sort of an appraising
Chinese cuisine or Chinese fashion or
music or whatever
well I mean because I think you're
looking at it the wrong way the Chinese
don't need us to adopt their culture
they don't need us to you know fall in
love with their brands all they need to
do is get the brands that they already
know to start spreading the messages
that the Chinese want them to spread so
in other words when you say you know the
Chinese aren't you know controlling
culture it's because you're looking for
a Chinese company to do it no that's not
the way of unrestricted warfare that's
not the way of War without rules it's
you get the companies that you like to
do to say the things that the Chinese
Communist party wants them to say so the
message so you're getting the same
messenger it's just the messaging that's
coming out of them is different and so
you know and you're already conditioned
to say okay this is coming from America
so it must be okay well no it's coming
from America but the message is Chinese
and so you know this is this is why we
you know and and I see see this in DC
all the time like oh the Chinese will
never like take over
they're not trying to take over in the
way that you think they're not trying to
make the face Chinese they're trying to
make the message Chinese
so if you are sufficiently reliant on
China for your trade for your money for
your distribution they can then have
leverage over the things that you do and
say back home you then become a conduit
for the message from the CCP okay cool I
understand
um I guess an example of that might be
that
um Warner Brothers that produce this new
Harry Potter film that had these seconds
of dialogue taken out of them they had
to do that in China over time let's say
that they were more Reliant increasingly
more reliant on China China would
perhaps say well actually we don't just
want you to take it out of the Chinese
version but we don't we don't want it in
any version perhaps right okay cool fine
and that's what Hollywood's been doing
right and you've seen that the other
thing that you notice and I I see this
all the time in movies that come out how
many times you know in in the last 10
years have you watched a movie and the
the the the hero coming to rescue
particularly science science fiction
films it's you know because set in the
future and it's a Chinese you know
astronaut oh they had to spend they're
saving the world wasn't that um
wasn't that the one when uh the Mars The
Martian wasn't it that China had the
exact rocket that we needed but it was a
second one and then we were going to
finally collaborate and they were going
to come out I can't remember that one
might have blown up as well but yeah I
do know I know exactly the sort of
narrative that you're talking about it's
also been a while since we've seen a big
Blockbuster action movie where China has
been the primary enemy you never see
that never it doesn't happen in fact uh
the one time that it was going to happen
which was the replay the remake of Red
Dawn they changed it to the North
Koreans
which I mean the North Koreans attacking
the United States are you kidding me I
mean
plot point it's like the stupidest thing
that I mean
it's hilarious you mentioned earlier on
unrestricted Warfare which is this book
from 1999 that I'd never heard of and
seems absolutely terrifying can you
explain what unrestricted Warfare is how
it came about everything else
yeah so it was written by these two pla
um Air Force Lieutenant Colonels and it
was basically their attempt to create a
Doctrine for how you compete with a more
uh militarily powerful Foe and it really
had to do with the fact that they saw
United States the United States as their
number one enemy but they didn't have
the wherewithal to go up against them
directly militarily how would you um how
would you deal with that problem so
there's two trends that they noticed one
was the internet and it was very early
beginning there but it was it was it was
growing rapidly and the other was
globalization and so essentially they
built a military Doctrine around how do
you um how do you exploit the internet
and um and globalization to uh overpower
a militarily superior foe that's so in
military
um in the military there's Doctrine and
the doctrine is basically based on
lessons learned of all the conflicts
you've had prior what are those
principles that you distill from those
lessons learned that allow you to plan
for future conflicts you know things
like mass or surprise or deception you
know how do you bring those principles
into the way that you think about war
what they did is they take they took
that and they built a a Doctrine around
how do you use the internet and
globalization to basically almost like
the Germans went around the French
magino line
how do you bypass the military which is
there to defend the sovereignty and
political independence of a society and
go right at the society itself and begin
to attack the society in a way that
number one doesn't highlight you as an
enemy and number two enables you to gain
specific Advantage advantages that your
adversary doesn't see happening right so
it's it's basically happening in the
day-to-day and you're basically losing
your political Independence and
sovereignty day by day by day as this uh
conflict unfolds
how impressive of a document is this it
seems pretty prescient it seems like
it's been able to predict what was going
to happen what does it feel like reading
it
well I mean so I read it in 99 and I
read it again in 2013 and and 99 I'm
like this is crazy
in 2013 you I read it and I'm like oh my
God
these guys so when you go back to you
know I flew b2s right so I'm an Airman
when you go back into the history of air
power and how that became used as a
weapon system very early on they're like
you know the Army we didn't have an Air
Force in the United States we had an
army the Army's like this thing's
useless for military there were
theorists back then saying okay this is
what you can do with an airplane built
guys like in the in the U.S general
Billy Mitchell in um in Italy's Julio
duhay
um they um they uh theorize that a
airplane could be a very powerful weapon
what these guys are saying in 1999 is
Holy Smokes this is the next evolution
of warfare here's the here is a weapon
even more powerful than the airplane and
here is how you use it so in a lot of
ways I got the opportunity like I'm I'm
you know Billy Mitchell was dead I think
when I was born
um I'm now getting to see the birth of a
whole different kind of warfare that you
know I everything else in the in in in
kind of air power sense is all history
to me you know things that I read about
this I'm actually getting I'm I'm able
to see and when you go back as an Airman
and you read the history and you think
like how could anybody have ever
disagreed with Billy Mitchell
and then you experience it yourself
because I'm like these guys are crazy
they're nuts there's no way you're going
to ever be able to do this and then I
see over the course of 20 years that
that's exactly what's happened I'm like
this is is you know as a as a military
guy I'm like wow this is really
interesting because
I I never saw this coming I I read the
document I thought it was nuts
and it actually came to pass that is
that's you know it's terrifying because
obviously it's successful but then you
got to say as a strategist or a military
thinker you're like that's pretty cool I
got to I got to see this unfold in real
time and be duped into thinking that
these guys are nuts they're not they
don't they don't know what they're
talking about why is it that they were
able to see something or have faith in a
trajectory that you thought at the time
was ridiculous
I think it has to do with the
circumstances of of what the Chinese
Communist party is it's primarily a
political organization and so the
people's Liberation Army is the party's
Army it is the armed component of the
Chinese Communist party and so when
you're a um and you know Klaus what says
war is politics by other means in other
words I use military force to achieve a
political outcome I couldn't have got
any other way but the Chinese don't
think that way and Mound didn't think
that way and you know through their 5
000 years of History there's a lot of
examples that they think a little bit
differently about Warfare and that is
it's much better to achieve your
objectives without going to war because
War carries with it the risk of losing
everything and so you know I think they
were already programmed you know so
Mao's concept of people's war is
embedded into the way the Chinese
Communist party and the people's
Liberation Army already think and that
that what that is is that politics is
war in other words it's not war is um
politics by the another means politics
is war and and that's a way you have to
approach it and if you approach it from
the standpoint that politics is war and
then you see these tools beginning to
um materialize that allows you to take
your political Warfare and Export it
globally to somebody else that's not
even in your borders and and do that you
know because the internet and the
globalization gives you the power to do
that
Boom the same way that the airplane you
know when paired with the logistics
might of the United States meant that
we're the most powerful military on
Earth the these two Colonels Lieutenant
Colonel said okay if I can take these
tools I can export the way that we think
about Warfare which is basically
political in nature how do we undermine
the faith and confidence of a society in
the governing structure of that society
and then how do we slowly turn those
Elites of that governing structure to
think of the world where you know they
um have the right to be in the
leadership position they have and that
by that right that the individuals below
them should just basically do what they
say that becomes the way that they
create safety because ultimately the
Chinese Communist party they just want
to exist and if the rest of the world
looks like they do and the people that
they're interacting with are the elites
of the rest of the countries and the
elites all agree right
they all agree that they are in charge
and everybody should do what they say
they don't care you know what your how
you describe that you can call it
American democracy you can call it the
EU democracy they don't care as long as
you have a separation between the
individual rights and what the elites
are allowed to do
how do you think that China sees their
enemies
um well they see everybody anybody
that's outside their borders is an enemy
and um
and uh you know the the whole adage an
enemy of my enemy is my friend so they
don't have strong alliances what they do
have is interest and then they use those
interests to play off their enemies
because again if politics is your way of
doing things then the more that you can
get your uh what you view as your
enemies
um to go after each other the less the
more secure you're going to be and so
you know Russia Iran North Korea you
know people think well they're allies of
the Chinese well in a sense they are but
in a sense the Chinese love it when the
Russians in the in the Iranians and the
North Koreans are basically creating
problems for America because the Chinese
also see the Russians the the in the
Iranians and the North Koreans as
adversaries right they're on their
border
um and they want to they want them to be
distracted and so getting all of these
nations to fight amongst themselves is a
perfect
um is a perfect and you think about
not just you know Russia Iran North
Korea but if you go to talk to any
American Ally in Asia Singapore the
Philippines right North or South Korea
what are the what do they constantly
tell American diplomats and uh and
leaders oh don't get us to choose we
want we want to do business with China
and we want to have you as a security
partner
so ultimately you're creating this thing
where you know the United States is not
able to grit a coalition to go against
China and China can't see the an
alliance materialize that can challenge
it right because everybody is really
unwilling to come together as a group to
challenge China That's essentially what
they're trying to work out so it's fine
that China doesn't have allies what they
want to ensure is that nobody else does
either and the way that you do that is
you constantly keep this
um this this uh
this this friction between and amongst
not just Russia Iran and North Korea but
also the democracies particularly where
uh China is concerned so one of the
things that's happened because a Russia
invaded Ukraine is the EU is now looking
even more forcefully at hey how do we
deal with China one of the things that
Chinese have been very very successful
at doing is taking the U.S and EU and
splitting them when it comes to China so
they have been very effective at at
splitting apart alliances particularly
when it comes to them and so they don't
need allies if nobody else has allies
yeah these uh loose coalitions with
whoever China has the uh friendships of
convenience rather than genuine
alliances that stand there and I mean
it is kind of like having the Playbook
open wide and you can almost see the The
Horizon coming a little bit when you
think look just consider everything that
China does as purely in its own
interests all that they care about is
them and if you can help them get on
their way then absolutely fine they're
going to be fine for that to happen
however the second that you can't
anymore they're not going to be bothered
and also they don't mind being ruthless
and culling you if needs be
it's um the more that I learn about it
the more sort of scary it it it seems
and it is such a effective way to
legislate or to run a country I'm not
saying that it's the best thing to do or
even a an optimal thing to do for the
people that live in it but you can get a
lot done if you're a dictatorship
well that's why Trudeau you know said I
wish I could be you know have a system
like China does and and essentially
that's what politicians in the west want
they want a system like China because
they think they can get a lot done and I
think what you know at least the framers
of the US Constitution uh particularly
guys like Alexander Hamilton that looked
at all prior uh governing structures and
said how do we fashion something where
nobody can gain ultimate power because
ultimate power is corrupting you know
this idea is losing favor in the world
and it's losing favor because the most
powerful uh country in the world is no
longer the United States it's now China
and its ability to move the narrative in
its favor means that this lust for
Liberty that came out of the American
Revolution and really found
um you know a home in so many nations
afterwards you know we've been in
existence over 240 years but all of that
is now lost its luster and even within
the United States you have the citizens
of the United States saying uh and and
not without you know the Chinese being
very involved in how they accelerate
that you know uh social
um unraveling that we are losing that
you know
what I would call you know Lust For
Freedom that really motivated our
ancestors to create this this uh this
system and so you know when I say you
know China is the most existential
threat that um not just America but
democracies ever faced I really believe
that because it's not about tanks moving
through the folder Gap it's not about
the armed might of the Soviet Union it's
really about us losing our lust for the
Constitutional protections that our
ancestors devised because they were
concerned about a government having
power over the people you know we have
people like Arnold Schwarzenegger who
came from former you know communist
country comes the United States finds
enormous wealth saying you know you
ought to do exactly what the um country
says you know because of um and you then
Freedom who who wants this Freedom you
know everybody should give up their
freedom for Corona virus and won't know
that the constitution was not designed
so that you just give up your freedoms
um for convenience it's designed that if
you give up your freedoms
then what happens is tyranny and
essentially you know once you give once
you give a politician an inch they're
going to take it a mile
I see from a politician's perspective
why a uh dictatorship would be so
seductive right because of democracies
it's just so much friction having to get
people to agree
all this voting all the campaigning all
of the problems with actually getting to
hear what people want and then having to
be accountable for making sure that you
deliver the thing that you to them that
you said that you're going to give them
like it does look from the outside
looking in if you forget about uh human
welfare and decency and and freedom and
liberty and all that stuff it actually
does look like a pretty effortful way to
run a country however yeah I am
it's so it's so interesting the way that
these policies have sort of looped back
around but you talk about the magic
shoes of Technology what are you
referring to there
well I mean I think what they are saying
is these um
when you look at the U.S in terms of
warfare we had kind of What's called the
first offset which was nuclear weapons
um and um and ICBM technology the second
offset was you know this use of uh GPS
um
stealth
um with aircraft networking computers
and and we were talking about in um in
2013 2014 at the Pentagon about the
third offset what was the third offset
going to be and I think what
um it's related to where the internet
where they thought the internet was
going and in particular this ability to
Target the individual so
John Warden talks about
um you know what you should go after uh
in terms of attacking a society in order
to have a successful military campaign
one of the things that you should not go
after is the population right because
rather than so bombing the population
really turns them again you know against
the people bombing them not the leaders
of the country if you're trying to
create a political outcome then you need
to go after the leaders of the country
because there's the ones that are going
to make the political decision based on
the pressure you put on them if you put
it on the population they're just gonna
it's gonna reinforce the rule
of the political Elite because it's
going to Garner their the people's
support against whoever's bombing them
so military force is not a good tool for
getting the population behind you and
what these two pla uh kernels tenant
Colonels saw was
you know the internet is a way to go
after the population add on an
individual basis so if I can get you to
change your perceptions your intentions
your behaviors using the internet now
I've got a tool to really change the the
game of warfare which is
Warfare being a political endeavor
um and if you can use populace or
populism as a way to go after the ruling
Elite and you can take these tools that
were created in Silicon Valley and go
after the population in a way that their
perceptions their intentions their
behaviors are modified in such a way
that you now like and here's an example
of the way that we used
um uh force in in the Kosovo War so we
basically in a nutshell went after the
assets of the elite supporting milosevic
and we took we started just taking away
night after night we were sending b2s to
Belgrade and other parts of Serbia to
take away their assets and and pretty
pretty quickly they realize hey I'm not
going to have anything if we don't stop
this and milosevic ended up being tried
for war crimes
well you can also go after the
population using the internet and begin
to get these same kind of outcomes and
that's what the Chinese so when you talk
about the magic shoes of Technology you
know we're moving from you know how do
you take a airplane and make it the
Ultimate Weapon on Earth
um for you know using Force to get a
political outcome to how do I take this
you know information technology and use
that as a weapon to get my outcome and
at far less risk and at far less cost
and instead of targeting the elites
which I'm doing with the the the
military force I'm targeting the
population and all I want to do is get
them number one to not be
um aligned you know as one cohesive
whole and number two you know the the
narratives that they believe are you
know less and less supporting of the
governing structure of that system
they're in so it's a perfect if you
think about it you know it's a perfect
it's a perfect technology and that's
what you you know that's what they were
talking about
you've just described the last five
years of media Communications Bingo
that's what it's felt like you know a
lack of trust in the officials that are
supposed to run the country uh a lack of
faith in the organizations that are
supposed to dispense the news and the
media to us a lack of understanding or
even agreement around what true means a
lack of faith that the other people that
are in the country agree with you or
want the same things that are good for
the country a lack of agreement about
what is good for the country mutual
fractioning and distaste and
yeah I mean so I learned about the uh
internet research agency Russia's sort
of cyber disinformation unit and that
seemed pretty sophisticated just how
aggressive and mature is China's
disinformation process
well I mean it's it's I mean the
Russians are like I mean it's like
trying to compare you know
um uh you know Jay Paul Getty and you
know some guy that runs a local
convenience store you know so the guy
that runs a local convenience store he
may have a little bit of throw weight
but it's not like a Getty and you know
so that's the difference so they have
the same kind of you know maybe intent
in terms of what they're trying to do
but Getty can do it on a much bigger
scale and that's the thing with China
um the other thing you know where the
media's media is involved go look at who
the top five media companies are in the
United States and then go look at who
their shareholders are and then go look
at who those shareholders and look at
their relationships with China and you
begin to see the the the the problem
right
have you ever seen the um map of Disney
and how much stuff it owns you can go
and look online and there's a super high
quality image the reason it needs to be
super high quality is that when you look
at it normal sized everything's in type
0.1 font and you zoom in and you really
is that you thought you were getting a
varied meal no you're not getting a
varied meal it's all coming from the
same tree at the very very top right and
that's essentially what's happening with
the media and
um you know it's it's it's a it's a trap
it's it's a travesty it's it's it's a
tragedy too it is you know we look at
the media as a fourth estate in in the
United States and it's supposed to be
the honest broker it's supposed to step
in and say okay this is what the
government's telling you this is what's
actually going on because anybody that's
done policy uh in Washington DC can tell
you that policy comes from corporate and
comes from financial institutions it
doesn't come from you know the
um good intentions of uh uh citizen
servants that come citizen servants that
come to Washington D.C I mean they may
come with this idea of they're going to
change things if they don't if they
don't
um lose that lust for serving the people
what they end up doing I've seen a lot
of people do this they just end up
leaving they're like I'm so frustrated I
can't get anything done uh people don't
care and the ones that end up staying
they stay because they become enriched
by it and so
in many ways and there's a good book
Catherine Gale who was a businesswoman
uh in in Wisconsin had a food company
had an epiphany one day when she was
working on strategy for her company and
so she wrote this book called the
politics industry and so if you look at
China as kind of a one-party
um authoritarian system you know
Catherine Gale makes a very compelling
argument that America has become a dual
party authoritarian system where the
party's actually fight not amongst each
other
they fight amongst others right so
they're basically the idea that the
Democrats and the Republicans don't uh
agree on the issues is more or less the
theater that's put on that allows them
to have the control over the policy that
actually gets made and so
um and when you think about it from just
a foreign policy sense having been in
this for a long time and national
security policy you see that
whether you're on the Democratic side of
the Republican side the policies tend to
be pretty similar and then when you get
right down to Brass tax like how are we
going to do Telecom policy in the United
States how we're going to do energy
policy in the United States you know
there's a lot of
um
there's a lot of Industry influence on
how those things get done
you know so are you saying that the the
left and right is performative
disagreement
it's performative disagreement in order
to prevent the
um you know any kind of real
change that benefits those that aren't
in the ruling Elite is the best way to
and and I you know having seen this on
the policy side and seeing how effective
um that corporations were and financial
institutions were and getting what they
want and how ineffective you know the
average citizen was in getting what they
want it just really brought home to me
the power of you know
how we've we've basically used the rules
um to create a duopoly in the United
States so there's an appearance of
um you know that you have a choice but
in reality
a lot of these people are um have uh in
some respects their incentivized to
maintain the system as is because they
profit from it well the illusion of
choice is a great way to make people
feel like there's nothing to rise up
against the problem isn't the system
writ large the problem is those
Democrats or those Republicans or
whatever talking about the um the
military spending earlier on China had a
strategy of limited military spending
for a while didn't it
well I mean I don't know what you mean
by limited you know there's
um
I guess in the sense that
uh it did study the Soviet Union
and it did realize that the mistake the
Soviets made were were to spend 40
percent of GDP on the military so
um
you limited yes
um
I guess what what they would what they
were trying to do is make sure that
um the social contract in China is is is
this if you agree to give up your
Liberties
um to have anything to say with how the
countries run we Endeavor as a Chinese
Communist party to provide for you you
know to provide a job
um and uh as long as you give up those
Liberties that's the social contract and
so in order to do that
you know they may they kept military
spending at a modest level that being
said you know they don't spend on R D
because they steal everything and
um the
The Remnant B is such that you know the
purchasing power parity with regard to
the US and China means that every dollar
you know you know every Yuan spent is
like you know six dollars six American
dollars and so I think you know while
yes they have you know in in aggregate
they've spent less year over year than
the United States considerably less I
think what they get out of it is a lot
more and um and really their goal was
not so much to be a military power until
the time was right right so then until
they had grown the product productivity
of their society sufficiently
you know now they what they saw after
World War II is the US had the supply
chain you on the supply chain you
dictate to the world they wanted to own
the supply chain now they do now they
can start to build their military what
you're seeing that start to excel
they've just started to expand right so
it looks like they're really
aggressively are they
looking for getting ready for a
conventional conflict do you think oh
yeah they're gonna invade Taiwan that's
coming it's without a doubt and and the
the power that and might that they have
accrued over the last 20 years is
staggering it is
I mean
I'm not kidding when you know you could
basically cover every square inch of
Taiwan with the Weaponry that they've
developed it's gonna make uh
invasion of Ukraine oh my God
and they don't care about the people
right so if you don't care about the
people all you want is to land because
it because it fits your narrative you
know what you promise to the Chinese
people yeah you keep us in power we're
going to restore us to Greatness one of
them is is basically getting back Taiwan
you know that they have the bill and you
know any base that we have in the region
will be leveled to dust if we get in the
way I just don't think people realize
how much they've built over the last you
know 20 30 years it's just it's amazing
it's incredible what's happening in the
South China Sea at the moment
well I mean part of the South China Sea
is controlling the resources of the
South China Sea but also being able to
have
um so back in the 80s uh the Chinese
Communist Party gave an order to the pla
hey um uh we want you sorry what's the
pla the people's Liberation Army sorry
the military so they gave an order to
the military to control the South China
Sea and um what the pla uh came back and
said is like we don't have the resources
like you know in order for us to
maintain control of the South China Sea
you know we would need to have aircraft
carriers we don't have aircraft carriers
we don't have a Navy
um we just don't have the resources and
so the South China Sea Islands were
really fulfilling an order that the pla
had received you know decades earlier
and that the child that China just had
finally had the resources to actually go
out and build so they just built them
for aircraft carriers that don't move
and now they now they have the the
planes they have the ships they have the
fuel they have the logistics they have
everything they need to be sustained
down there and control it the other
thing that the other challenge in terms
of
um that China has with regard to Taiwan
is they know that they can be cut off
from resources energy resources raw
materials so they built the Belton Road
initiative which is essentially a way in
in they describe it as we're going to
look West and what what that means is
you know
bringing oil through the Strait of
Malacca is really how they get energy
well that can easily be blockaded by
submarines right so now how do I get my
energy well I want to have this belt and
Road initiative that allows me to go
into Pakistan going to Rand go into
North Africa and Middle East and get my
resources another way so that you can't
block me out in the Strait of Milwaukee
it's also has to do with Russia Eastern
um East
Central Asia
it's really getting all the resources uh
from there and allowing the the Chinese
to really have an alternative Source uh
for raw materials and energy and food
when they invade Taiwan so when you look
at what happened when Russia invaded
Ukraine part of the benefit that the
Chinese get to see in watching the
Russians you invade Ukraine is to see
the response of the West right what are
the things that the West does because
what what China wanted to do is if I can
see that response
then I know what to plan for oh you
think that's that was a dry run for time
I think it's a dry run for Taiwan and
and that's why you think about it from
the Chinese perspective that's why
because
Putin went to she
and basically she said hey wait until
after the Olympics but he got the green
light from she what she wanted out that
was to see you know how the not just how
the Russian military performed
um because I would say that the Chinese
military are much more professional much
more uh much better equipped much better
trained than the Russians but it's also
like how the how's the West going to
react and in some
you know I'm just sitting back as a
strategist right I'm watching this play
out and I'm like and you know you're
like okay this really this bad thing's
gonna happen over here and I have this
you know bad thing happening right here
and you're like should I go in guns
blazing here and let that guy know
that's going to be even a bigger problem
know what my guns are you know you're
looking at this and you're like watching
it happen in real time like why are we
showing them this
right we should not be it should not be
guns blazes because Russia is not the
power they've got an economy less than
the size of Texas
China is the power they are basically
getting all and we're we've taken out
the Playbook and throwing the whole
thing in at Russia and now we have
nothing left and not only that but now
China is beginning to take its it's kind
of the way it looks at its sphere of the
world and beginning to create the
mechanisms so when they move into Taiwan
we're going to be like I can't do that
one can't do that one and can't do that
one and we're just gonna be sitting
there and and people are going to be
upset they're going to be frustrated
like why can we not do something well
the reason we can't do anything is
because we showed all our cards
vis-a-vis Russia and I'm not saying this
as hey we shouldn't support Ukraine I'm
just telling you what we've done is
we've given we've given the Chinese the
keys to Victory uh over Taiwan without
ever having to really break a sweat I
mean that's the thing that scares me
this is one of those videos that
resurfaces online
three years later in the middle of a
crisis and everybody goes the the signs
were there the signs were there this
this everybody knew it and go uh okay
uh I I it really is It's a combination
of awe and dreads that I kind of look at
um what China is able to do right it is
unbelievably sophisticated and and very
very impressive
the only problem is that it's being used
to facilitate a regime that a lot of us
don't want to have happen
um it's it is pretty pretty scary one of
the other things that I thought about
and I've seen stories on was their role
in the fentanyl crisis that was
happening in America how how
sophisticated or purposeful was that
well
um the beauty of China again the the
systems engineering to society right
getting people to do things that are in
their own interests and um and making
sure that the things that they they
don't do they don't do because they know
there will be consequences so it doesn't
matter where you're going in the world
today if you're getting fentanyl it
comes from the same place it comes from
China and it comes from not from you
know like in uh like in the U.S Midwest
where you got a guy uh in a in a trailer
house out in the middle of nowhere you
know blowing himself up it's coming in
factories right they're making it in
factories and so and so you're like well
how is it that China doesn't have a
fentanyl problem if that's the source
how is it there's no fentanyl problem in
China well very easy the Chinese know
that they're making fentanyl they can
make all they want and they can profit
off it all they want just don't sell it
in China or they end up dead so
and so really
um what the Chinese they have a really
in when it comes to how you make your
money they don't care as long as it
doesn't impact the party right if you
don't if you're if you're if you don't
impact the party then you'll have at it
if it actually helps the party even
better so if you can get rich and it
helps a party even better uh one of the
most sick examples of this is organ
harvesting in Chinese prisons who are
who are having their organs harvested
healthy people who are the healthy
people their religious dissidents the
falun gong the the uyghurs right so you
get in there you live a healthy
lifestyle you're a good uh you know uh
candidate for organ transplant boom your
dad what's take your organs and sell
them guess what the people that run the
prisons and the hospitals get to make
you know the tens of thousands of
dollars from selling your organs okay so
they get rich
but the you know the party gets rid of
their uh their enemy which is you know
these religious what they call religious
fanatics
sick terrible but you know and it works
in the system fentanyl is the same way
you have the the the Chinese
pharmaceutical companies making the
making the drugs selling it through the
Triads and the cartels so that's the
redistribution mechanism because I was
wondering how it is that China gets it
out of that country and into America
yeah so the Triads are a big part of it
um Sam Cooper who's a um an
investigative journalist in Canada wrote
a good book willful blindness talks
about you know you know how it works at
least in Canada I wish he'd come in the
United States and and and do the same
thing
um and then because in the United States
it's killing people you know great and
the way so this is why this Warfare this
type of warfare is so effective the doj
the FBI they look at drugs as abhorrent
Behavior you know it's it's it's
criminal Behavior it's Behavior outside
the norm remember we said we're gonna
China's gonna systemize things and we're
gonna get rid of abort Behavior our
system basically expects citizens to act
you know you know in you know in Con in
in in uh in the in the best they they
expect citizens to be lawful
right they expect the citizens to act in
their own best interest which also
happen to be in the best interest of the
society and therefore the only ones that
are going to be doing these bad things
are people that are bad and so let's
create a system that where everybody's
trusted and then the bad people we just
go after and we catch them they're
criminals and we lock them up
well when you look at that and you say
hey um
you know this is just criminal Behavior
but it's supported by a system that's
systemic then you don't have the either
the perception or the tools to deal with
it and the the analogy that I um
that I like to use is you know I tell
people to say what if you're what if
your you know Dad came home and he said
hey we've got a big ant hill in the
backyard I want you to get rid of ant
hill
and you go out there and you set up an
ambush point where the ants are walking
by and you start killing ants and your
dad comes home later in the afternoon he
says well how did you get rid of that
hill and like how how successful have
you been and you say well um you say I
you know I had set up this Ambush point
and I was killing I'm 100 affected every
ant has come by this this in the last
you know several hours I've killed every
I'm 100 effective I'm really doing a
good job dad and he's like but the ant
Hill's still there right so it's the
same thing for um for FBI if they lock
up a criminal boom win you know and my
stick statistics are I keep locking up
more and more criminals but are you
slowing the flow of fentanyl to the
United States no they're not it's
actually increasing so what's going on
there well it's a systemic thing you
know so in order to get you know the
Chinese Communist party runs everything
in China in order to get the Chinese
Communist party to stop shipping
fentanyl the United States
it has to be painful on the elites and
what Chinese have done is when you
inflict pain on the Chinese Elites
you're also inflicting pain on your own
Elites right we move the supply chain
over there so the way that you get the
Chinese to stop shipping you fentanyl is
you say you're not going to ship
anything to this country until the
fentanyl stops right what happens your
own Elites come to you and say we can't
have that because I'm going to lose
money right so you right away you've cut
off any ability that you have to solve
this problem because it's a systemic
problem people in China are getting rich
people in America are dying that means
that you're doing well individually the
party's doing well because it sees the
us as an enemy and we've created a
system that that really prevents us from
doing anything about it other than just
like we were talking about between
republics and Democrats in a
performative basis right the FBI can try
it out hey we we arrested these three
people uh or we got the Chinese to
arrest three people which by the way are
out in two weeks so it's it it's it's
it's it's Warfare on a different label
and you have to basically take a step
back and say
and when I so
when I uh went to China I did not think
this way I completely believed that our
relationship with China wasn't that good
I wanted to go back to China and work
there and it wasn't until I really
started to understand the Chinese
Communist party when I was working in
the Pentagon later on
um that I really began to see you have
to look at the problem differently if
you don't look at the problem
differently then slowly you know what
those businesses in Shanghai were
telling me that we're going to make
China and us no they're going to make us
into them and that's that's the problem
you've got this quote from Sun Tzu on
how to deploy a stealth war in your book
it says all Warfare is based on
Deception let your plans be dark and
impenetrable as night and when you move
fall like a thunderbolt he Advocates
using spies and agents to study and
demoralize the enemy to the point when
an attack comes the end the outcome is
decided attack a defeated enemy he
cancels the Army is the coup de grass
hearing that makes me pretty scared and
it also makes me think that I'm guessing
if we got to the stage where China
actually declared a war it would already
be too late yeah I would be we would
basically capitulate I mean that's their
goal is to basically say
you know things are over but you know
that being said they're they're pretty
good at just you know so if Wars if the
way we think of War it's a political out
you're it's it's politics by their means
if slowly you're getting the political
outcomes that you want and so boy the by
the point where you you know would need
to go to war you already find that your
your adversary agrees with you there is
no point for war and and so
you know the things that that that blow
my mind like just blow my mind
um that I found out in the last two
years is Imperial College of London you
know which puts out put out the uh
epidemiology model that said you know
all these people are going to die from
coronavirus now I looked at that model
and I compared it to the data coming out
of Italy Italy was very hard hit very
early on with the coronavirus but the
model was so out of whack from what the
data you were actually seeing in in
Italy I'm like this is crazy this is not
this these this num this model is not
correct well the model is what was used
to basically get us to accept that
lockdowns and all these other measures
are required
what blew my mind and what I didn't know
until Michael Singer had done the
research and presented it to me is that
in 2015 Xi Jinping had gone to the
Imperial College of London that the
Chinese Communist party was giving them
tens of million dollars that Neil
Ferguson the epidemiologist that was
putting out the models was basically on
the payroll of the Chinese Communist
party you want to talk about deception I
mean that's beautiful it's beautiful you
get your the fear that you want to
create comes right out of your enemy's
own mouth I mean that's that is
sophistication
dude it's terrifying it's terrifying
you've blown my mind today I really
really enjoyed the book If people want
to keep up to date with what you do and
find out more where should they go
I'm on Twitter at Robert underscore
Spalding no you and Spalding
um I'm on uh I'm on uh LinkedIn and uh
an Instagram General Spalding uh
generalspalding.com is my website and uh
and you'll see the book there General
Spaulding I appreciate you thank you
thank you what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace